Thanks so much.
Thank you rob.
And thank you for having me here today.
I'm not quite sure how I'm going to compete with next week's program.
Um,
but having said that,
I've already spoken at one of the Google event and that was a Zeitgeist a few
years ago.
Uh,
when I was basically chairing the likes of Stephen Hawking,
David Attenborough was their Mo Farah was leaving the morning run.
Um,
so I'm not quite sure how to compete with their mind that I can't really tell
you about the secrets behind quantum physics.
I'm not sure I'm going to be much use improving your personal best.
Are they 800 meters?
And I've no idea what lies beneath the ocean floor.
Um,
but instead I'm going to try and tell him the space of half an hour or so,
a little bit about the secrets of the global economy.
What are those economic forces,
uh,
that shift around all our fortunes,
what lies beneath and what lies beneath that global power base.
And the way it's changing all of that for the price of a dollar bit of a bug in
there for lunch time.
Uh,
but,
uh,
the almost dollar,
the book I've written is about more than that.
In fact,
um,
I was an economist at the start of my career.
I still am.
Um,
but I made the worst economic decision of my career some years ago when I
decided to swap a trading floor for the world of broadcasting.
Uh,
yeah,
I follow it would mean,
you know,
pretty decent money and better hours.
Neither of those two in case anybody else is thinking of making a similar move.
But the reason I did it above everything else is because I was frustrated at the
way the economics was viewed as this,
not just the dismal science,
but the distance science that people didn't understand.
It didn't matter to them.
It was too complicated.
Why should we try and explain it?
It was worthy,
but frankly doll.
Um,
and I'm afraid that image has continued.
So in that sense,
I feel like I've failed.
I feel like entire world's media frankly has felt,
because this is what we think about.
Of course,
when we talk about economics,
we think about big players,
big pictures,
big numbers.
Um,
and I'm sure some of you here would have been,
uh,
at Davos in recent years,
so you could probably recognize those two photos at the top.
There are others there.
The sheer,
and what really struck me as at a time when we're talking about the rise of
populism,
about dissatisfaction amongst people around the globe,
about their lots in life.
What have we got?
We've got the world's political leaders and financial leaders running their
hands over the issues of inequality and stagnant wages and the rise of the right
all walls sipping their hundred franc glasses of champagne,
determine what,
whether or not to have a 50 front,
a Croque Monsieur,
um,
and returned to the thousand francs a night rooms.
None of which is an exaggeration.
It's not a cheap place to be.
It's how I as town in Europe,
it feels a long way from many of the day to day issues that affect people.
But I have a strong feeling,
but those forces shouldn't be viewed in the abstract.
Like that isn't the case.
That was big players actually debate and determine our forces.
The other image,
of course,
we always talk about when we talk about the world's financial systems markets
that I pick thing Wall Street,
the Bulls and the bears,
uh,
trillions of dollars changing hands,
some of the products,
even the people there,
uh,
on the New York Stock Exchange floor don't understand what they're all about.
It's all beyond our understanding.
It's all beyond our control,
isn't it?
That water?
I think because even though that's the big picture,
I think ultimately what we need to talk about is the smallest forces.
And that comes down to frankly the individual dollar.
And it is the dollar.
I mean,
because even though we've got all these currencies flying around the globe,
it's the dollar that's king.
You call it what you like in,
call it the dead president.
You can call it a single in call it a green bag.
Um,
but it is the thing as much as I started this,
this is the thing really that is driving all our forces.
Why the dollar?
Well,
it is the international currency of trade and we can blame history for about one
more on that in a second.
It's also the security blanket,
but governments and central banks clink to around the world.
It's the world's reserve currency.
You have that stored away in case there is a rainy day as well as in case you
need it for trade and things like that.
And again,
there is a reason why they cling to that dollar.
It's seen as being stable.
It's seen as being the globes,
common financial language,
you know,
people will accept it all in the way.
Of course they wouldn't accept a bitcoin just yet.
And because of that image of security and stability,
the dollar is also a common way of holding your deaths as well.
Uh,
loans may between countries loads made a across borders between companies as
well.
So in actual fact,
if you look the American population as well,
5% of the world total maximum,
but the dollar comes up and 40% or transactions around the world,
it's also the currency in which 40% of loans are made as well.
So it's punching way above its weight
bit.
Now about the history of the dollar though because,
um,
well that's not the history that although that's a world common language doesn't
matter.
Uh,
and it's really,
it is the common language that is driving everything.
But,
uh,
when you look at it,
it's had a little bit of a checkered past and uh,
let's just talk a bit more about that history then can be a bit of a glimpse
that history of the green greenback from behemoth to the Bronx.
Well,
it all,
uh,
despite the name,
um,
and despite everything we've heard about it isn't actual fact American at all.
There's no more American than I was to start with to be honest.
Because what you've got there is originally what was known as a Thaller file,
a coin.
And those were minted in the behemoth as an original wound where,
uh,
you can see that 15,
25 mentored m what was then Bohemia,
now,
what we'd call the Czech Republic and those silver coins.
We used natural fat across Europe for hundreds of years.
And if you look back at popular culture,
they prop up time and time again.
Shakespeare was quite fond of actually talking about dollars and it comes up,
I think it's a second scene in Macbeth,
they talk about $10,000,
which is a little bit odd because that bath for those who like theater setting,
the Lemp century,
so dollars weren't even around back then.
So a bit of artistic license that then of course we saw the dollar being adopted
as the currency in the u s and again,
we have gentleman over there,
uh,
Alexander Hamilton to thank again,
storming,
uh,
Broadway and the west end right now.
So there's some kind of connection there.
I'm not quite sure between the greenback and a and the stage,
but uh,
we have him to thank and that currency has endured.
So for much we talk about the rise of say the RMB or the euro or even digital
currencies.
The dollar somehow has managed to keep its head high for us all those years and
an actual fight.
It's continuing.
Having said that,
there had been various bumps in the road.
This was something that none of us are going to remember.
Of course,
this was the great depression when we saw the value of shares dropping by all Mr
quarter over the course of four or five days.
And once the investors had finished dumping their shares,
what do they do next?
They started dumping their dollars,
exchanging them for gold because they were so concerned about the world's most
popular currency as it was back then,
which meant great demand for gold.
The American central bank are very worried about the value of the dollar.
So what does it do to try and prop up that interest?
Keep investors hanging onto them.
It put up interest rates.
It's of course,
that's one way of ensuring that people want to buy your currency.
They get a better return.
Who pays a price for that?
Well,
this is what happens.
You end up with 25% of your working age population out of work.
The people who have got jobs,
uh,
probably are underemployed working part time when they want to work even longer
hours.
So that was the great depression,
GDP output falling by up to a third over that period,
the economy scarred and damaged.
Having said that,
there was actually launched the end of the tunnel for the dollar.
And this is something that we get back to a dollar again and I sort to show you
that see flip over a dollar.
Um,
and if you're ever stuck in a,
in an immigration Q at Jfk or fine,
it's a great way to pass the time.
Um,
they go,
there's a symbol on the back there,
which no one quite knows the meaning of it.
And if you look at it that it's 1935 that went on the dollar and many people
looking at it,
that's a masonic symbol,
right?
Uh,
in actual fact when they looked into it,
the engravers who put it there weren't masons.
So no one's quite sure what it means,
why it's there.
But if you look at it in detail,
there's the,
I've got up there,
God favors are undertaking and at the bottom,
the new world order,
and it was on Fdr that that was put on.
Um,
and you know,
straight up,
cause he's psychic.
Nobody quite knows.
But it did actually,
was it quite an accurate predictor of the way things were going to turn out?
Because what happened after the Second World War is there was a conference at a
town called Bretton Woods you probably heard of,
which was set up to enable,
there'll be lasting peace,
financial stability around the globe.
What came out of it was in many ways,
the main vector of the Second World War,
and that was the dollar.
It was cemented the,
as the international currency of trade and also that currency of last resort,
that current c that was being used primarily for the bank's reserves.
It was linked to the value of gold.
It was referred to as being as good as gold and all the other currencies in turn
had their values actually linked to that.
Um,
that particular setup didn't last,
but the legacy of all that was that to this day,
as I was saying a little bit earlier,
we still do use,
uh,
the dollar as the currency for doing trade and,
and also as that security blanket.
And what does that mean?
Well,
ultimately,
whether we like it or not,
whether we're using dollars every day,
whether we're seeing them,
whether they electronic and is touching all our lives every day.
Uh,
and through the choices we make that impact on the economic forces around the
world and the way the influence and power shifts as well.
So what I thought I do was have a look at the dollar and it's journey around the
globe.
Look at a sort of series of episodes of what might happen if you followed a
dollar around the globe.
What does that tell us about the,
is there,
and it's not,
it's not an unusual journey.
That's $12 billion notes.
Insect classroom is traveling and about half of them are outside of the u s half
of them,
which sounds extraordinary when you put it that way.
Uh,
but they are.
So it's not an unusual journey by any means.
So in terms of looking at that journey,
let's start in the home of the big spender,
less store in the US where a one in six of every dollars of GDP,
output income,
however you would look at it,
each year is generated in the form of consumer spending.
So,
you know,
it's a nation of big shoppers.
And even though that's something that people look upon as being a negative,
it's a very important thing indeed.
And this particular transaction,
we're going to look at something that happens every day.
But when I look at,
uh,
a shopper who does what many of us do shopping trip and that you just chucked
something in the trolley,
they wants me to Ikea,
you know exactly how this work should come out spending more than you thought
with things you think.
I didn't really need that,
but it's in there anyway.
Am I example,
I looked at a woman who'd been in a Texan Brunch,
but that'd be Texas of Walmart who puts a regimen to hedge,
rolling.
Um,
and uh,
it's cheap.
It's going to give her some German in the kitchen while she's cooking dinner
that night.
But the main thing is it's made in China.
And that's something that is a very important relationship and deed because
Walmart,
it's all about piling it high,
selling it cheap.
That's the logo it was basically founded on many years ago.
Uh,
and to make that happen increasingly it means turning to China to supply the
lines.
You've got to,
uh,
tens of thousands of suppliers in China just making stuff for Walmart.
Walmart actually buys more from China than the whole Germany does.
That's how important that relationship has.
Um,
between the both they've come up with the liners that can make the journey
across in five days.
Um,
which is,
as you can imagine,
a pretty busy route right now.
Of course,
the ships going back the other way on Nina's for which adds up to something
quite different.
This has quite a big impact of course,
on the American economy.
I lived in New York about a decade ago and this bridge in New Jersey in Trenton
always fascinated me is the Trenton bridge.
And,
uh,
it's lit up.
Say Trenton makes the world takes,
it's been there for a hundred years and a hundred years ago.
That was true because of course what we saw then was America very much making
what it consumed.
If you put a radio back then it was like to have been built in that factory up
there,
which is in Pennsylvania,
that's taken in 1925 so just a couple of hours down the road from the Trenton
Bridge.
But that's all changed since then.
If you're buying a radio in America,
chances are it's not made in America at all.
Um,
we've now got much cheaper labor elsewhere.
Of course,
if you look at the size of the working age population in China,
uh,
it's my times the size of the hut in the US.
So it's no wonder for many other reasons as well that Labor is a lot cheaper
over there.
You got cheaper labor.
You've also got various governments around the world giving their industries are
helping heart.
What does the ad up to legal things like that and like that still plant at the
bottom.
Lying,
uh,
derelict.
Uh,
the rustbelt has turned very much to dust.
So what does America actually making?
It's making shoppers.
It's making people who are buying goods from abroad.
And that all adds up to a massive big trade deficit that you guys,
her $566 billion.
Um,
president Trump talks about 800 billion.
He actually got that role.
Um,
that's a matter of goods they buy in and this is the goods buying bought 10
minus of goods going out.
Uh,
but what he has actually touched a nerve with obviously is what this means.
The American economy.
The fact that if America's not making,
if it's buying from elsewhere,
that does impact on incomes,
it does impact on output,
it impacts on jobs,
hence make America great again.
It's not everything though.
Um,
there are some things that a America still excels and Boeing is saying that over
the next couple of decades and expects to get $1 trillion worth of orders from,
uh,
which is extraordinary when you consider the way Chinese manufacturing is
evolving.
But that's because America is still excels in the higher tech areas of
manufacturing is still has a speciality.
It has a comparative advantage,
but you can't live off airplanes of course.
So we've now got this trade war emerging on the other side of the Atlantic.
Um,
what does that mean?
Well,
it means that tr Trump puts up barriers and things like steel and aluminum
saying everybody else is playing on fairly.
This is putting my manufacturers out of business,
the likes of retaliate saying,
okay,
we're going to put charge and things that you still make like Levi's jeans and,
and um,
Harley Davidson's.
No one wins course because what you end up with high prices,
you end up with less business being done.
Ultimately you end up with less output.
The cost of actually making those things goes up as well.
So in many ways it's the populations both who are losers and that's why we've
seen trade wars coming down rather than coming up in the last few years.
But what does this mean for China?
Well,
course if America is taking China's making,
so what happening there in the Shins and factories?
Uh,
so many of them now,
uh,
you know,
20,000 suppliers,
they're grinding out stuff for Walmart.
That altogether you've got the Po River Delta,
which is the biggest mega city now on the planet.
Um,
but what all those producers have in common is that a then all allowed to hang
onto the dollars.
They make,
uh,
those dollars get funneled up instead for the financial system,
to the central bank who's got a very specific use of mindful than uh,
and all of that is down to what's dictated by the Chinese government.
Of course,
they are in the Great Hall of the people that are on the end edge of gentleman
square.
And for many years they've sort of said,
right,
okay,
we are all about producing.
We are going to become the world's factories and workshops.
In recent years.
The cracks are started to show and that policy,
because you've got,
you know,
Vietnam wages and our fifth of what they are in China.
So the likes of h and,
m,
they started to look elsewhere and say,
I'm going to buy my garments and Vietnam instead.
What does that mean for China?
Well,
they also had to contend with their optimal for the financial crisis when world
trade fell by over 15% in the course of just months.
So they know this isn't a banker,
they have to think about diversifying.
So they're trying to create also a nation of consumers.
Uh,
so no wonder the Alibaba has overtaken Walmart when it comes to sales and is now
the biggest retailer on,
uh,
but back to what Chinese people do with the dollar.
This is a really fascinating one because
it's got all these dollars.
What do you do with them?
You can't stick.
And we were under the mattress by any means.
One of the things,
of course,
one of the reasons why,
um,
China's hung on so tightly to dollars.
It's because it wants to control its exchange rate.
Why is that?
Well,
the cheaper your exchange rate,
the lower exchange rate,
the cheaper your export are,
the more attractive they are.
And that is one of the reasons why we have seen all this trade complaints coming
up in recent years.
Also,
of course,
it's one of the reasons why you never hear the American government talking about
wanting the dollar to be stronger because that's bad news for producers.
So by keeping control of the RMP,
it puts the Chinese government in a very strange position because if you're
controlling your exchange rates,
you're controlling the amount of your currency that can fly around the world,
which means that your currency is not going to be able to take on the dollar
when it comes to popularity of use around the globe.
So you're giving up some power in that sense.
What it does with all these dollars though,
the Chinese is actually quite conservative when it comes to investing.
So they like to go out and buy American bones,
American government bonds.
That's the form by which the American government borrows issues.
These bonds,
quite a low rate of return,
but it's a pretty standard,
you know,
pretty stable one,
the Chinese government lost that because,
um,
they know that Uncle Sam is good for the money.
Um,
these are also what's known as liquid.
So you can,
you can cash them in quite easily.
Um,
they're also what's known as a deep assets,
which means that if you go and buy,
some of them are,
so some of them,
there are so many of them around,
you're not going to impact the price.
There is a sense of stability there as well,
which makes it very popular.
What does that mean for the American people?
Will China owns some of its debt?
Uh,
so in theory that means that China could hold America to ransom and practice.
Actually lots of other countries.
Won't those bonds Tuesdays always a buyer for them?
Um,
it does mean however the,
because they're so popular,
the American government comparator,
very low interest rate.
And that means that in turn American people can enjoy lower interest rate.
So there's some payback there.
There's also something else that I'm trying to use as installers for,
and that is,
uh,
to invest abroad something that's become very popular in recent years.
And for China,
it means that donors are the key to growing its economic empire beyond that
shows.
This is the old Silk Road,
which you weren't remember unless you're around and the times of the Roman
Empire.
Um,
originally used to bring all this,
the new one,
but the old one was meant to bring silk to Europe and also bought things like
carrots the other way.
Uh,
now the Chinese government is investing billions,
trillions even in building a new maritime and uh,
also the road silk road,
uh,
to try and increase its trade passages and also increase its influence as well.
All of those Newbie,
I don't know the companies,
the mergers and acquisitions going on as well.
For the first time in 2014,
China invest more money abroad than means being invested in China.
It's an interesting switch of position there.
Why?
Because China is thinking about how it grows.
It's influenced,
uh,
around the globe and it's not just those roots you can see there on the map
because if you're investing at all or as the Chinese government,
you might send it somewhere like Nigeria,
which is what I looked at next.
Why Nigeria?
Well,
this is a very,
very strange one in today because they're building railroad.
Why would you build a railroad in Nigeria?
$12 billion worth of railroad.
It goes from caliber,
which is a port town to Lagos,
the financial capital.
It crosses some oil fields and that's the clear,
uh,
China needs oil to develop.
Nigeria has it.
China wants to have influence over as well fields.
It might want to get some of those contracts.
What better way than being a friend of Nigeria is exerting some soft power mean
at that kind of economic diplomacy,
building a railroad,
they're enabling people to get around as well.
And for cargo to get around in a country where Roe journeys,
uh,
quite perilous and railroads are currently very underdeveloped,
quite new to Nigeria isn't that they get railroads,
they get infrastructure.
Uh,
China gets some jobs as well through its work as Nigeria gets some jobs as well.
But there's a downside of course,
because by succeeding some of your,
um,
territory there by accepting China's dollars,
your lunch without saying well,
but giving up some power as well.
So that's one reason why when we talk about the oil wealth of Nigeria,
very,
very little of it actually passes into local hands because it's foreign
companies,
foreign money that's coming in and actually paying into those things and reaping
the gains at the same time.
And it's more than that as well.
That's the market in Lagos.
Now you can see that some of the local cloth,
they're being sold huge source of income.
They're very popular.
But now you tend to find it's about a dollar a yard I think on average.
But the Chinese imports are on the cutting that substantially.
So what you're saying is local traders,
they are being put out of business
and uh,
what we've seen the last few years,
it's investment.
They're overcoming the level of aid given to Nigeria,
which is there are lots of questions about what is the answer when you've got as
Nigeria has Nigeria had huge problems with the famine,
uh,
not that long ago.
Um,
partly because of conflict in the country.
What do you do in a situation like that?
Is,
is it all about investment is about aid?
Well,
both coming strings attached seems to be the answer.
Even aid nowadays.
Um,
there's all sorts of concerns about the right types of products,
projects,
the right kind of appropriation funds as well.
So it's one of those debates that keeps going on.
And if you want to develop,
I mean do what infrastructure,
uh,
like Nigeria is getting of China.
If you get it from China,
there's gonna be strings attached if you get it through aid as well.
Is that the answer?
But the other thing that of course,
uh,
Nigeria,
Nigeria also has to import a lot of food because one of the problems about being
an economy that has been subject to so much conflict as it has been,
is that an actual fact,
your national dish,
if it's rice and you can't grow enough,
it's got to come from elsewhere.
So I follow that dollar to India.
Next,
I have to see exactly what would happen if you then had to buy your rice from
India.
Um,
and that's quite a popular route and nitrify because even though we think about
individual countries producing commodities,
that money goes through middlemen.
It goes through four or five major commodities traders and they trade in
dollars,
which is what I was still talking about dollars right now.
So that brings us to India and India is a really interesting example here of how
you look at growth and prosperity because you've got the rice balls there and
you're over 165 million tons of rice produced by India last year at secondary to
China in that regard.
But on the other hand you've got two thirds of the population of working age in
India,
employed in agriculture,
um,
them still live in poverty,
the only about 10% as productive as the American counterparts.
And that's where a number of reasons,
you've got things like a tiny farms,
poor land rights pour you some machinery,
low levels of technology,
um,
and then on top of that,
your infrastructure so bad that even if you manage to produce that killer of
rice,
up to a half of it might have gone off by the time it gets the ports it was
destined for.
And then there's the middle man as well.
There's those big commodities traders.
So the average Indian is not seeing very much of the value of what they're
trying to produce.
The and then a strange situation where the country can't feed itself.
Therefore,
and also many farmers can't make a living.
That's one side of the engine economy.
We know it's the fastest growing major economy right now.
Why?
I don't need to tell you actually in this room,
you probably,
they want to already.
It's all to do with tech.
And the fact that 25 years ago we were looking at a tech industry that was worth
about $2 billion now,
well in excess of 100 billion.
Of course.
Uh,
I won't go into any more of that because you know all about how successful that
has been in terms of propelling the tech industry around the globe.
But it means that in just taking a very strange route to get there,
because
most countries undergo and industrial revolution,
right?
Entered an index,
kind of jumped ahead it.
When I'm not doing industrial revolution,
I'm not to export in like China dead manufactured goods.
I'm going to go straight to tech.
Does it need to have the middleman?
Probably.
Yes.
Um,
if you look at what's going on in India,
you've got 65 million people living in slums.
People moving out from rural areas say,
I can't afford to live here.
I'm moving to the cities,
but there's nothing for them.
So the government's trying to get a handle on that by saying,
well,
we need to think more about investing.
They're trying to attract foreign money,
which is quite a departure for the Indian government and also trying to involve
more technology.
Uh,
they also tried the strange experiment of doing away with 500,000 prepared
notes,
a demonetization,
uh,
partly to weed out the informal economy tax evaders a dodgy activities.
India is an unusually cash based economy.
Um,
didn't quite work because the people who are professional enough to be dodging
taxes and you know,
the big time is we're actually able to put them on until the things as well.
Gold jewelers we're working through the night,
people really suffered and that kind of experiment or housewives,
the people who had money hidden under the bed because they couldn't explain
where it came from.
So they couldn't exchange it for the new notes.
So it didn't quite work there.
But on the other hand,
one of the things that did happen is you'd see a greater growth or things like
her.
Well,
digital banking took off in a big way.
And also you get things like ritual drivers who now except digital payments as
well.
So it did have some impact.
But really the government when it's trying to modernize,
has to look at more traditional roots.
It has to look at things like investing.
Um,
it also has to look at building roads.
As I mentioned that an awful lot of produce gets wasted simply because it
doesn't have the rose to connect.
It's 650,000 villages,
uh,
but it wants to change that.
So the government's got very ambitious road building project,
uh,
upwards depending on which estimate they want to quote and which day.
It's either 20 kilometers or 25 months.
So it's quite a big difference between the two.
But,
uh,
we'll just,
we'll just accept what they're trying to build more roads.
Uh,
but to build roads,
you need oil because oil is what goes into road surfaces as well as into the
cars and trucks that drive on them.
We're going to get the oil from if you're in India.
Uh,
how about rock?
So let's follow that dollar on to Iraq.
Okay.
And that is the,
uh,
miss an oil fields that's near bounce rough
and they put a very particular type of all because even though we talk about
crude oil,
there's different grades of all right.
The stuff that goes into calls is typically light sweet oil,
don't drink it.
It's just called that because of the way it flows.
Um,
and uh,
because of the way it evaporates as well for spelled the stuff you use.
And rose is the heavier grades,
a sour grades.
Um,
it tells me a bit cheaper as well.
And uh,
they all felt embarrassed when they realize that they can actually get away.
We're splitting this into the course of stuff and selling that on a discount.
And India is quite literally lapping that up.
So He'd got already customer that it's not just India.
If you look across the world,
um,
on average,
each man,
woman and child uses the equivalent of over two liters of crude orcas,
crude oil per day.
If you look at consumption across the globe,
that's going particularly fast of course in countries like China and India.
So there was a steady supply that I studied.
Amanda,
you would think that equals power,
right?
Not necessarily having oil doesn't always mean you have more power.
Well,
when I go there is dollars.
Uh,
and that's a very specific reason for that.
In the 1970s,
Saudi Arabia and the U s did a deal whereby the US said,
well,
you can use our dollars and in return you'll have the protection of our foreign
policy.
You have our backing.
And Sadie went,
thanks very much.
That's great.
And in return we'll make sure we have a special relationship with you.
You're big gas guzzlers and I'm sure we can make this work.
And it has worked ever since.
Uh,
but,
uh,
what Saudi has found and of course last week we saw a great delegation visiting
10 Downing Street almost cap in hand because Saudi has discovered that having
oil doesn't necessarily equal riches forever.
Even if demand's going up,
the price can fluctuate from year to year quite a bit.
And,
uh,
those prices are determined on global markets.
And even though Saudi Arabia and other countries that got together to form OPEC
and try and influence that price,
they don't have much impact.
And it's got so bad.
Now the Saudi Arabia,
like many other countries can no longer balance its books based on the oil
revenues getting is trying to diversify.
Um,
many countries find that actually having natural resources like that,
um,
can be what's called the paradox of plenty.
You think you've got this rich scene,
but it kind of open up your economy to all sorts of vulnerability.
Uh,
there is the fluctuation in price.
Um,
there is also,
there's this thing called Dutch disease.
When they found all the North Sea,
um,
the Netherlands thought great fortunes are made and actual fact because the
demand for the currency was like,
right,
the exchange rate shot up or the industry's couldn't cope with that.
And what we saw was the unemployment rising at a time when it's selling a lot of
oil and the economy being in trouble also as a,
if you're in Nigeria or indeed Iraq,
you'd know for well,
but where there's all the tends to be conflict and for iis course grabbing oil
fields in Iraq was a major source of income for many years.
And that means that,
uh,
the Iraqi government,
all those got many things.
It probably feels it could be doing with our oil income.
It's very Alliant on oil income instead has to use parts of it to actually
defend its oil fields.
So what did you do with that?
Well,
we're going to go over a well worn path now because,
uh,
heading off to Russia,
a lot of arms,
uh,
that you'll find,
and this is true,
when I s a ripped open bonds,
uh,
dating back to times of Saddam Hussein and stole weapons in Iraq,
many of them had basically made in Russia or the equivalent printed on the side.
And there's a reason for this as well.
Okay.
Um,
the Cold War and Russia of course was obsessed with churning out weaponry to
show that if you compete with America so much so that it neglects almost all
other forms of manufacturing.
It was all about creating the means destruction.
And it was all very much along.
So the planning lines,
you had quotas for how much you produced,
how it was produced,
father's followed,
you know,
their songs fall it on,
uh,
the factory dictated your every way of life,
your housing,
what was in your houses.
Thousands Times are now gone.
But,
uh,
Russia then found work.
This was still its area of expertise.
It's still,
um,
very much at the forefront.
It's second only to America and the way they sell as well.
Uh,
they sell to their friends.
So America,
suppliers,
the rest of NATO,
for example,
Saudi Arabia,
uh,
Russia,
a lot of the developing world,
but again,
Russia is going to have to about how it,
uh,
how that changes over the coming years because China saying he can make this
stuff cheaper.
Um,
and,
uh,
also Russian soldiers,
I find himself quite often staring down the barrel of guns that were designed in
their country weapons falling into the wrong hands.
And that's before you consider all the ethics or the doc site or creating the
means of destruction as well.
There's two things that Russia is dependent on for the money.
It gets its weapons and also oil.
Um,
it's economy overall has been pretty unstable and that goes all the way back to
the times of the Cold War before.
So we'll rush it was churning out arm to protect its border and it's cities.
America's currency during the Cold War was actually having a heyday,
um,
everyone from hotels to prostitutes and Moscow,
we're accepting dollars.
Why?
Because you could use those to spend in hard currency stores,
which had stocks well times and shelves were empty elsewhere.
And uh,
you know,
we may think of Russia pulling strings today,
um,
in terms of,
uh,
fixing collections or fake news or have we going to look at it.
But,
uh,
America is still holds an economic power and that's still true for this day.
Um,
why?
Because it was all about trust.
People didn't trust the ruble and money.
It's about trust.
You've got to trust its value.
That's going to keep that value.
It's going to be an acceptable means of exchange.
And it's something you can use to repay debt.
The dollar fits the bill a lot better than the ruble throughout the Cold War and
indeed since as well,
a lot of the oligarchs.
So they want to keep their money safe,
hold onto it in dollars,
but it comes,
the toilet comes with some strange powers attached.
A cartoon that,
um,
that was in a newspaper just after the raids on fifth has headquarters in
Geneva,
which was all orchestrated by the Americans.
Why do the Americans care?
They don't even care about football,
you know,
they call it soccer.
Um,
they did care because the whole bribery scandal had touched the American
financial system.
It had touched the dollar at anything that does fat means that America has
jurisdiction to go out there and take action.
And that's exactly what they did.
Another way that Americans tried to,
will's economic power along with Europe of course,
is sanctions after Russia's actions in Ukraine a few years ago.
And that has driven the Russian economy further to its knees into recession.
And of course also created a bit of a crisis in confidence in the robot.
And that too has been good for the dollar.
A lot of people who aren't actually affected by sanctions try and keep their
money in dollars and that's quite often elsewhere.
If you don't want those individuals who has been affected by sanctions,
what Ma you put your money.
How about uh,
Germany?
What?
Well,
okay.
Uh,
because partly of the friendship between these two and they didn't always look
so friendly.
Apparently at that first meeting Putin brought along his black Labrador.
Uh,
sounds like a friendly thing to do,
but uncle Merkel or has a lifelong fear of dogs after being bitten.
So some saw that as her being terrorized by him,
but since then they seem to have grown a warmer and cozier relationship and
there's good reason for that.
40% of gas supplied to Germany comes from Russia.
So effectively Russia is keeping the lights on in Germany over the winter.
Um,
so Germany therefore has been a little bit more reticent about applying
sanctions on Russia.
Uh,
they've also been a little bit more welcoming to money coming in from Russia and
Germany has a long history of thriving on investment.
The Marshall Plan,
both the money,
those guys,
again,
it was not the u s treasury secretary who,
uh,
donated some dollars equivalent of 170 $140 billion,
in 2017 money after the second world war to rebuild in Germany.
Um,
sounds very altruistic,
but it also came about because America was concerned otherwise,
Germany,
uh,
would fall into the hands of communists and therefore they'd be facing another
opponent.
I'll also meant ready market for their goods.
That was the idea is that of which Germany grew into a massive industrial
superpower and also created the financial system that you need to enable that
kind of growth.
Um,
Russia has a lot of money in Germany stay as well that the refinery,
um,
invested in by the Russian energy supplies and natural fat Russian energy
supplies account about half of Russian money going into Germany today.
But it also means that a,
it's an attractive place.
For example,
if you're an arms dealer who's got a dollar that you want to use for your
retirement plan,
what could you do a good buy property in Berlin for example.
Um,
and that's the kind of example I looked at in the bank and the book rather,
all that money plowing is Germany means of course the biggest economy in Europe.
Now it's been the architect or the single market and also the kingpin behind the
year.
Took a couple of minutes,
talk about the euro because um,
we are as an interesting one.
Uh,
American bankers are really scared about the creation of the euro.
they thought it will take over from the dollar as the world's leading currency
as most Amerind currency hasn't quite happened via stove and central bank's
reserves.
It's still seen as a source of stability,
but some say it with a sense of suspicion partly because of the way the year it
came about.
Um,
and that was because there was various entry criteria,
you know,
all the countries joining it had to be basically driving at the same speed in
the same direction.
They fudge some of the rules for that one for Germany as much as for Greece.
Um,
so what you ended up with was economies who very quickly became quite clear that
one is interest rate wasn't going to suit all their interests.
Uh,
that's quite different cost to America where you've got one currency,
one interest rate on one political system as well.
And those cracks became even clearer during the time of the financial crisis
when it became quite clear.
Like Greece for example,
was an all sorts of problems and Germany wasn't that keen on bailing out Greece.
They would very different economies.
And because of that,
the questions are still being asked about the future of the year
and a that's throwing the whole,
it's whole credibility into question.
And he carries on the UK of course decided after several tests,
uh,
not to join the year.
It looks at everything even looked at how much molesballs custody in each
European country,
um,
to try and compare how convergent they were with each other.
But it's decided not to and at the time and thought that was a huge mistake and
that what we find instead was that Germany would be the,
in the outside,
uh,
in fact it became the world's largest financial center is not going to continue.
Well,
um,
of course the dollar lies beneath a lot of the financial crisis.
But the UK being the financial center of what we saw was the,
um,
crisis starting in America.
Homeowners,
it couldn't repay loans.
Banks would repackage those loans into investment products.
They didn't really understand those collapsed financial system.
Over here feels a wall balls.
You get cues outside of banks like northern rock.
And then we get constant of easing.
We get all that money pumped in effectively meant to create loans to be dolled
up and institutions.
Does that work?
Well,
the global economy is back on its feet again.
So it seems to have worked.
On the other hand,
when you look at the evidence,
only a small part of that money seems to have been filtering through into
consumption.
Most of it seems to just bumped up asset prices once again.
Debt levels are now at a point now where people are worrying again about,
uh,
the possibility of another financial crisis.
But another thing that worries people is whether or not we can remain the
financial capital.
We've still got the dollars flowing in partly a consequence of location
language.
And as we all know,
London's the best place in the world to live,
but a,
the way the conversations are going now between the government and the European
Council,
that might be something that's under drafting.
And,
uh,
of course,
so many businesses now are looking elsewhere for trade deal.
So I talk about the toilet going back home because you've got a business person
that,
uh,
picking up a dollar at the foreign exchange bureau,
um,
to go back to Houston and over in Houston pays it over to the concierge of his
hotel who happens to be the woman we see at the beginning buying her radio and a
that throws up questions about whether America can be made great again.
And it also touches on this disease is very real disease,
which is,
uh,
the productivity puzzle,
which is affecting the whole of the Western world at the moment,
which is that per hour,
we've not really seen output increase in any great speed since the financial.
Why is that?
We've had a lack of investment.
No,
it's of course,
um,
there's all the technology and the fact that we may not be measuring face things
properly.
Whatever is going on there.
Until we sought out that puzzle,
we're not going to be able to compete,
uh,
with the emerging globe.
So we're looking at all these journeys around the world.
One thing becomes clear,
it's the dollar that's keeping globalization in business.
Um,
and it's not the big dollars.
It's the small dollars which add up to very big some indeed.
It's all those individual decisions people are taking around the globe.
Uh,
what kind of goods to buy,
where to buy them,
all from where to invest their money.
And that's how those economic tides are turning.
And as those tides turn,
it's creating a global shift as well.
And power bases.
What's keeping the wheels turning?
It's not so much real money.
It's a matching money.
It's all that debt we've created and we've learned a lot of lessons since the
financial crisis that the central banks don't want to know about it.
Many of us don't want to know about it.
It keeps all finances going,
but it's that,
that's the big elephant in the room.
What does the future look like?
Well,
we could see their R and B if the Chinese government changed their ass cheat a
bit,
uh,
coming up the stakes.
We could see the year,
oh,
perhaps looking a little bit more solid.
Digital currencies might with future,
although at the moment I think it's a bubble,
but at the moment it's the dollar that's still reigns supreme.
Keep
[inaudible]
why we have about 10 minutes of questions.
We'll go with a hard half one finish.
If you have meetings,
I will kick off with the question.
What is your opinion on big tech?
So if you think that Amazon,
for example,
is taking a huge amount of consumer dollars,
what's your opinion on that and perhaps where that might lead us in the future?
And if you have a question please.
Behind,
um,
as in whether it's a force for good,
yes.
And perhaps comparable to nation states,
for example,
with,
you know,
if you think how much Amazon has compared with smaller GDP countries.
Sure.
Um,
it's a bit like the dollar really,
isn't it?
Yeah.
It has traverse
nation states.
Uh,
is it a force for good?
I think it's,
it's,
it's basically what it does is epitomizes the way our global economy is changing
and it'll minimize all those forces of globalization.
It's like,
Yep,
we're all using consumer power to get the American dream on the cheap.
Right?
And we all want,
but uh,
what are you sacrificing your sacrificing perhaps the things that,
uh,
you know,
we've come to hold dear things like employment practices and things like that.
So I think you're looking at Amazon in particular.
There's pros and cons.
It's a bit like making America great again,
isn't it?
You can buy cheap,
but there was a price
I want to,
to ask a question about the choice of telling a story about the dollar because I
imagine is an economist you reviews lots of models,
models are [inaudible].
I have described these phenomena and I was just interested that you've gone with
this narrative approach and you know,
whether you've tried,
communicates with models and failed.
So communicating those kinds of models through journalism or whatever and maybe
it doesn't work.
Okay.
Uh,
yes,
it doesn't work.
People distrust models,
uh,
because they don't understand that when we've had recently in the news,
of course,
all this thing about economic forecasters have no idea what they're talking
about.
I used to be an economic forecaster and yeah,
you know,
there are models,
um,
and they're very good models and there are,
I mean the treasury for example in the UK employs hundreds of people sit that
programming and coming up with these things and testing them and constantly
changing them as the Bank of England by also know,
having been an economist and muck cause these models that what you get out,
it depends on what you put in,
right?
So you can make various assumptions and that will impact on what you get out.
So I'm a little bit cautious sometimes about extolling the virtues of models too
much.
You kind of,
you painted a very loose picture about uh,
how complicated the global system is.
Obviously 2008,
2007 shows that economists don't have all the answers.
Do you still trust the economists,
macro economists specifically?
Um,
and yeah,
I guess a little bit more information around those,
around those models and are we perhaps measuring the right thing?
I caught,
remember some of my head,
there was a conversation recently about GDP not measuring a certain aspect of
the productive economy.
And incorporating new things into it.
I guess just your thoughts around that would be interesting.
Uh,
yeah.
do I trust the economists?
Um,
good question.
I think it's a bit like,
it's been like being an astrologer or a weather forecaster,
isn't it up to a certain point.
You get a lot of bad press when you get it wrong and it's easy to get it wrong.
Um,
and those are all those jokes about economists in a room and you get more views
than there are economists.
I think in terms of analyzing the facts and I think I'm not columnists job
should be to pull apart the fights,
see the underlying picture.
Um,
what we found in recent years in particular is that politics,
personalities to have tend to obscure all those fights and the underlying
trends.
Um,
I think economists could do a better job and bringing those to light when it
comes to predicting things.
I think we've got a little bit too complacent about looking at the past.
And a lot of economists who were working around the time of the financial crisis
quite honestly have never seen,
uh,
a proper recession.
You'd have to go back to the 70s and see a really strong economic shock.
They just want use to it.
And our models had kind of got a bit complacent too.
Um,
so,
and you mentioned their GDP.
Yeah.
I,
you know,
this is a really interesting point about whether we measured the world's
wellbeing and forms or the amount of income we can generate and there's much
more to the picture.
Um,
that measurement of income doesn't take account of a lot of things.
It doesn't take account of the fact that,
you know,
you might go home after a 12 hour day and you've still got a whole load of DIY
to do or housework or whatever.
None of that counts.
There's a famous of Humira,
your cleaner,
um,
you're reducing GDP
because before that the clean is output classed as part of GDP.
Mary,
the cleaner and it's just counted as domestic work,
which doesn't show up.
Also.
Now,
GDP doesn't measure things like environmental impact.
Um,
technological change,
which is one of the things that was written about recently is the fact that,
um,
when you look at GDP measures,
they haven't taken account the way that technology's moved in recent years and
therefore many ways we're underestimating the health of the global economy.
So there's a lot more work to be done on that.
And I think it's something that now we've got past the seismic shocks of the
financial crisis.
Central banks are finally waking up and paying attention.
Uh,
when you give out a loan,
you have some kind of expectation that you get the money back.
But given that,
um,
uh,
countries have such a big,
adapting,
you know,
in particular the u s why does it not all collapsed because you know,
is,
is it feasible that you can get the money back?
Um,
as a people,
we can get the,
my back,
the America's counting,
America's counting the fact that everyone wants American particular is counting
on the fact that everyone wants dollars to trade and to keep in bank reserves.
And that's why it can sell those bonds.
That's why he can fund its deficits and ultimately its debts.
Um,
it means that America was seen as being good for the money.
But yeah,
if every bond hold,
I,
if America and Japan,
China,
Japan got together and said,
what do you think?
Should we ask for Armani bike that could undermine the economy?
It's one reason why the yen has never taken off in a big way as a major reserve
currency because investors around the globe,
I've been so concerned about the state of the amount of debt Japan has,
that they don't see it as being a stable and therefore ultimately attractive
economy.
But because the dollar has a special status because it's required for other
things,
America doesn't solve that problem.
Oh,
I'll go with one more and then we'll round off.
Um,
what do you think outsiders outside of Brexit,
what's perhaps the next big thing coming down the line that we should be aware
of?
The Pepsi Paul on top.
Is it,
is it aging population?
Is it unforeseen,
uh,
tech AI outputs?
You know,
what,
what's,
what's front of your mind that we should be,
we should be thinking about.
Yeah.
I had something up there about aging population,
which I didn't talk about because as conscious of time,
but um,
as we're talking about here,
um,
Phillip Hammond's on his feet talking about the state of public finances here in
the UK.
He's talking about the next couple of years.
But to me the big problem that's looming for all of us is the fact that
populations are aging and that puts a whole different kind of emphasis on the
finances.
We have public finances and private finances and the,
we live the way we work and the way we fund everything.
Um,
I don't think any government has really thought that one through.
And every time they tried to stick a toe in the water,
uh,
things like dementia tax,
of course,
hugely controversial,
but there is a valid issue hiding under all of that,
that somehow we're going to have to think of the fact that the average person is
over 64,
uh,
cost four times as much and healthcare as someone under the age of 16.
And someone's going to have to pay for that bell,
but going to live longer,
I going to live better and longer,
hopefully.
But how do we pay for that?
And I think that's something that has to be the subject of much debate.
And hopefully Sam at Davos might get their heads around it as well.
[inaudible].